foreign
person we generally interview on this
show he's not a political figure he's
not still boxing why did we talk to him
well because Mike Tyson has spent almost
40 years at the very Pinnacle of
American society and then at the very
bottom he went to prison at one point
he's seen everything
and a lot of people who lead lives like
that are destroyed by them they become
numb and insensible particularly if
they're boxers but a rare few become
wise and fascinating and able to
communicate what they've learned and
Tyson is definitely in that category
so for brand new episode of Tucker
Carlson today we sat down with Tyson and
we began by asking him
what was it like growing up here's part
of that
[Music]
I'm not shaving much I'm really proud of
my childhood yep yeah but no advantages
yeah my disadvantage with my advantage
what do you mean
um my adversity inspired me to be more
than what I've truly was
I believe that
so you
are inspired by Ali then you go to a
different reform school and they have a
former fighter there who trains you is
that the point when you realize you're
going to do this for a living yeah but
this is the thing when I came there I
was in another facility on that campus
and I believe I
if I don't want that stabbed somebody
but I had an altercation with somebody
so I came and he met me I had handcuffs
and I'm re-arrested and I was a mess and
so
went out and when the guys were talking
to me because they wanted they said well
you're not a bad guy because you did
that so we thought he said we have an ex
fighter Bobby stew you need to meet him
he'll probably get you in shape and I
said well I'd love to meet him I met
Muhammad Ali I've seen Muhammad Ali one
and then this guy knocks on my door I
heard you want to talk what do you want
I I want to be a funny thing everybody
wants to be a fighting show me you want
to be a fighter let's just see how your
conduct is and I went from being a
really jerky nasty guy to be coming to
HD
yeah
um and then he started training me
what was it about that is the discipline
that he imposed yes I wanted to be a
fighter so bad
if you hadn't become a professional
boxer what would you have done there's
no doubt that was gonna be that champ
you knew you were going to be at what
age
um
13. 14. and four years later you were
oh seven years later seven years later
so when did you meet Custom Auto
when I was 12.
um I was at the facility and the guy
drove me to me though
because I made my levels in there I was
a trustee now yes I was a good kid to
trustee so I can go to get um I can get
off campus and go visit them what was he
like
total disciplinarian yeah take note yeah
yeah that's what I need not a week not a
weak man those kinds of weakness yeah no
side of the week if you didn't conduct
yourself the way he conducted yourself
you're not Italian
he's going to tell you what Italian is
if you if he thought like one of those
guys poorly show up what's the poorly
name the Italian Guys the Jersey Shore
guy yeah they're not Italian it's
because they're Italian they are not
Italian
he would say something like that if you
don't conduct yourself Italian money
conduct themselves like this
he's not Italian
he was he was that kind of guy
I mean he's saying so when what was he
playful nothing playful very playful we
had the teeth and put behind his back
because nothing playful about him and
you liked that hey you know what I loved
it someone cared about me yeah
and if anybody face unto me a punch him
in the face and Tackle
so it's so interesting because most
teenage boys wasn't about me you attack
you physically
were you ever afraid
I was always afraid of him I'm afraid of
him now like dead
he made sure you're afraid of him
and you like that listen we we're on the
third floor right we're talking crap
yeah we're talking about girls and stuff
and then we hear him he's coming
everybody stop talking and then he comes
and said hey I heard everybody dance
laughing from the first floor I called
hey not laugh I want to know what's
funny I want to laugh too and nothing
because we were just talking
stop laughing why
and you know the guy he scared enough to
say anything
but I mean you're like twice as big as
him no
nope at the um
he had the system of intimidation down
like a science
really he had it down to a science how
what were his methods not talking you
know he
um God languages language without making
I'm making sounds yeah so you understand
if he's mad or not
look at that
oh look at me it's a little boy so happy
to be with this guy look how big I am at
14. you're 14. yeah look how big I am
yeah you're enormous
baby
UE
so did he and I pardon my bad memory did
he live to see you become no he died a
year before not even less than a year
really eight nine months something like
that
and he by that point I think was your
guardian right yeah my mother signed me
over to him before she died
how old were you when she died 16 16.
so he wasn't just your coach he was your
mentor and your leader yeah if I didn't
make them fight I still had to be there
you know we had to get a job I still had
to be there did you live with him yeah I
think that was third fourth thirteen
you lived at his house yeah
so different Hey listen
anytime I saw a white guy was a judge a
copper he was a victim and I come to
this guy house and this guy showed me
love and um wow love is powerful one of
the reasons I wanted to interview you is
because you're the author of one of my
favorite quotes
ever in English which is everybody's got
a plan until he gets hit in the face 100
because people now especially now no
one's gonna fight people like talking
now they get on the stage they get on
YouTube and they start talking yeah and
that's why some people
some people are not made for handling
credit handling criticism they're just
not made some people go off the deep in
which you criticize them yes some people
just can't handle it and some of the
most powerful people in the world you
can't handle it they're not mature if
they handle criticism
were have you gotten better at handing
criticism as you've gotten older yes but
mostly um
yeah but it's still you think it can get
even better
sometimes I get sometimes I get in my
head and think I'm somebody
and then I'm easily offended but when I
know I'm nobody I could never be
offended
boy is that a deep Insight sometimes I
get in my head that I'm somebody and I'm
easily offended and then I remind myself
I'm nobody and I'm not offended exactly
100 percent
so if you you know if you're that well
known and everywhere you go people are
sucking up to you and taking pictures
with you how do you
remind yourself as you said that
actually I'm nobody well I don't know
God God did that for this and this is
what he gave me it's not like someone
gave me something I didn't um acquire I
wanted this life I prayed for this life
and I received it
thank you
when I think I'm somebody I'm offended
or I remember I'm nobody I'm not there's
a lot more in that vein tomorrow Tyson
talks about his faith and his love of
animals really one of the most
remarkable conversations we've ever had
and then he describes how he really felt
about the men he fought in the ring over
the years and we'll just give you a
preview I wanted to kill them
but you knew that
stay tuned for that absolutely worth
watching
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight